last time you were you're here you you
burned a Donald Trump tie this before
the election do you have regrets about
that now that he's actually our
president-elect you know I actually I
just think he ended up being a very good
con man and whatever I was trying to do
there which is really just to entertain
people cuz I think a lot of people
didn't just didn't think that he could
win right could have grabbed him by the
in the White House right but I think I'm
trying to think of this as we're not a
nation divided we're a nation that's
kind of broken right now and anything
that's broken can be fixed mm-hmm right
he had a better slogan than she did so
we all this is an opportunity right with
an emphasis on unity I'm making t-shirts
and II okay I'm not gonna sell them I'm
sorry that I made them and there's a
bunker yeah ten point something out yeah
hold on you've been telling us your ear
is bleeding well you know you see this
but this ear is bleeding just a little
it's well here's what happened so my
friend Megan oh you know here's the
unity thing she's told everybody the
lesbian community is talking about
wearing you know this it doesn't mean
that you're gay or straight it just
means that you share similar values and
you won't allow people to be harassed
and then there's the safety pin movement
and I I just you know if you look right
there wait a minute I'm sorry did you
just did you just put that in my eye
backstage I did it last minute cuz my
wife Kate was like you know you should
you know you should you should show
solidarity are you okay you want a
band-aid or something no I'm fine I'm
fine
I'm on I'm on television and my parents
are watching this you're embarrassing me
Conant okay all right all right how much
I'm bleeding okay all right well let's
get on to the next question you're in
this movie with Jennifer Aniston
Jason Bateman what's it like working
with these big stars well with great is
that they are
yeah the the dial that they the notches
that they cut it there just so
meticulous such comedic icons for me and
Bateman would say let me do the series
of all and it's just so small what he
does you know he think if you did the
line five times and it was it was like
it was like yeah that sounds well good
luck with that
yep well good luck with that
yeah well good luck with that yeah good
luck we can't forget it yeah yeah that's
what he was I'm sorry I'm kidding
I am a little dizzy yeah are you gonna
be okay
I think I'm gonna be fine all right you
know again I want people to go and just
take the holidays off we've got a lot of
work to do wait why are you guys
treating me like this you know the
audience's believe gross you're really
making me feel uncomfortable I'm on
national television right now trying to
tell you to see the movie take the the
holidays to drink too much eggnog okay
and also to watch comedy because we've
got a lot of work to do in 2017 and I
really am dizzy dizzy dizzy you're
getting very dizzy can you are very
troubling the owner of this estate
you've been in your oh yeah you put it
in your coat yeah that's what yeah yeah
you're not hardcore yeah sure all right
now I'm dizzy enough that I'm having
trouble telling whose two terms Andy and
Conan I like no it's really funny over
in this area
all right listen okay we're gonna get a
little break we're gonna take a little
break you gonna be okay yeah we're gonna
take care of you we'll be back with more
TJ Miller to second
[Applause]
you